c'est un travail de ruches mécanique ici
est la ferté-saint-aubin 5 millions de
pots de miel par an sont produits mais
cette année un nouveau type de
récipients fait son apparition le verre
duralex donc là notre innovation le pôle
duralex avec lusinchi à moins de 20
kilomètres de chez nous donc un impact
carbone très faible 1 1000ème france est
un pur franc pourtant français est la
deuxième vie dans du produit puisque les
gens se serviront d'un verre à la maison
pour pour moi pour faire ce qu'ils
veulent avec ici
le miel est mise en pot et assemblée
depuis 1999 avec 15 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires l'année dernière la
famille vacher est la deuxième marque
apicole française et même la clé
sanitaire n'a pas enrayé cette dynamique
on a doublé notre production on est beau
c'est quasiment du 7 sur 7
ça a été pour nous enfin très très très
dur
mars avril on a eu des chiffres qu'on
double et on a fait + 80 pendant deux
mois donc on s'y attendait pas vraiment
mais les marchés la vente directe était
fermée nous on travaille quasiment que
avec la grande distribution
donc c'est vrai qu'on a bénéficié d'un
effet d'aubaine florent vacher a alors
le luxe de pouvoir se projeter et dans
sa tête
les idées bourg dun il veut dépasser son
rôle d'agent de conditionnement du miel
j'ai un projet de le faire une école un
centre de formation de l'apiculture et
qui sera sur comment on peut consommer
du miel de ma différemment que au petit
déjeuner sur les tartines
c'est à dire où par exemple des masses
de beauté ou de la cuisine ou
de toutes sortes de consommation du miel
l'entrepreneur pense déjà au coup
d'après pour lui le miel de demain
passera par la vente en vrac